people have got to know whether or not
their presidents a crook well I'm not a
crook I call President Obama and Hillary
Clinton the founders of Isis they're the
founders do you like your insurance plan
you will keep it the Iraqi regime
possesses biological and chemical
weapons according to Gallup and most
other polling organizations Americans
have a record or near record low rate of
confidence in government just 39 percent
of US approved at Donald Trump's
performance in his second quarter as
president almost 25 points off the
historical average a mere 36 percent of
us have a lot of faith in public schools
only slightly more than a quarter of us
trust the criminal justice system and
just 12 percent of us say we have a
great deal of or quite a lot of
confidence in Congress trust in most
major institutions is lower than it was
a decade ago now a lot of libertarians
and other skeptics of government see
this trend and believe that people are
finally waking up to reality but there
are good reasons to be concerned about
persistently low levels of trust and
confidence in government researchers
routinely find that people in countries
with bad governments want more
government intervention in all aspects
of their lives even though they don't
trust the government to be fair or
effective one 2010 study found that 82%
of former East Germans and 92 percent of
Russians - famously low trust
populations favored wage controls
residents in Scandinavian North America
which are high trust regions were far
more trusting of market forces so it
turns out that government may be growing
not in spite of our lack of confidence
in it but because of our lack of
confidence in it president now has the
worst job approval rating since modern
polling began this self-defeating spiral
will only get worse
if the United States fails to stem its
slight or being a low trust country the
solution to this doesn't have to be
nihilism or Anarchy instead we need a
government that does fewer things but
does them better government spending is
at an already swollen 21 percent of GDP
and is predicted to climb to 30 percent
over the next three decades libertarians
rightly want a limited government and we
should fight like hell to end cronyism
drug prohibition
and regulatory overreach that does
nothing but increase the cost of doing
business
we need to keep pushing back against the
fence spending wasted on elective Wars
and national security measures that put
us under surveillance without making us
safer but we should also point to places
where government action is both
legitimate and effective and praised
policies like school choice for instance
that deliver better results at cheaper
costs for more kids ironically if we can
get more people to trust the government
it just might be easier for us to shrink
the size scope and spending of the state
[Music]